I want to start today with something
that is really important and really
worth doing but I also need to be
careful because I know the emails I'm
going to get after we do this story
emails saying David how dare you
perpetuate anti-white racism on your
program what you're doing is only okay
because it's about white people if you
did the same segment about black people
it would be so inappropriate but racism
for some reason because of the left is
acceptable against whites but not
against anybody else no that is not what
this is about last week I pointed out
according to a New York Times poll that
among uneducated white voters Donald
Trump has a massive lead but he loses
educated white voters he loses Hispanic
voters he loses black voters he loses
biracial voters Native American voters
whatever the numbers came from a New
York Times poll
and they're very interesting Trump
crushing Biden Sanders and Warren among
white voters with no college education
but losing among white voters with
college losing among black voters losing
among Hispanic voters and others the
reason that we are separating educated
white voters and uneducated white voters
is because all of the other groups are
against Donald Trump both when they are
and are not educated so understand that
that's why the story is done this way
and it's an important story to do and
when I did the story last week
I got all sorts of comments defending
these principled uneducated voters they
are good people too and they're not
worthless because they don't have a
college education I agree no one is
worthless period that is actually in
line with my politics regardless of
education but the point is what is it
about being uneducated and white that
connects with voting for Trump that's a
real political question when we
discussed it last week one person left
the comment quote it's almost like
education opens your mind to a larger
world view okay another said
anti-intellectualism is a major aspect
of the Republican Party
they need people to be uneducated in
order to remain in power and they know
it these are not racist comments Now CNN
did something interesting over the
weekend they interviewed six white
female voters without college degrees
some had voted for Obama before voting
for Trump and others had not but they
all say we've voted for Democrats and
Republicans in our lives and this is
really important when we consider 2020.
these voters white uneducated voters in
swing States
are going to be important in 2020 so
check out whether these are people you
are comfortable with making decisions
about who leads our country not because
of the race because of what they say
okay the three women who voted Obama in
2012 and then Trump 2016 are asked how
could you vote for both how did you vote
for Obama and then Trump why and take a
listen to some of the answers okay so
Marion explain how you were able to vote
for both I voted for Trump because he
was not a politician you get tired of
the same old same old from
Washington that and I really wanted
someone that would make big changes
president Trump he said he was going to
take care of us and he was going to make
sure we had more money in our paychecks
and and help us out because you go to
work you work hard and you have nothing
and then there's people that don't even
work that have more than I do so this is
why education matters they fell for an
empty talking point that has no meaning
whatsoever I'm not a politician so vote
for me that's not objectively good right
it was one of the ways Trump tricked
people you may not be a politician but
you're part of the establishment status
quo that funds politicians and
perpetuates the system we have and
you've used everything from lying on
your taxes uh uh and and credit bank
applications loan applications to hiring
undocumented immigrant labor in order to
line your pockets you're not better
because you're not a politician you're
just bad in a different way if you were
more educated you're less likely to fall
for a talking point like that this is
not about elitism it's about uh uh
having gone through a process where one
learns ideally
to think things through for themselves
learns critical thinking you aren't bad
if you didn't go to college you're not
even dumb because you didn't go to
college and many people are able to
learn these things outside of college
but we're talking about tens of millions
of people here who are more likely to
fall for these empty talking points
let's continue has your life
economically financially improved under
President Trump I have I have a lot more
in my paycheck I I do have more in my
paycheck as well
my stock portfolio is doing great
maybe that's why I look at the economy
different
um I'm not where a lot of you are
financially I don't think I'm pretty
darn low income once again I have more
money in my paycheck this was one of the
biggest ruses of the Trump tax reform
and unless you know how to think about
it you get tricked like some of these
folks did the Trump tax plan included
changes to the withholding tables so
lots of people ended up with more money
in their paycheck week to week but a
smaller refund at the end of the year
but what matters is what was the total
tax that you paid I've given this
example before if I give you an extra
hundred dollars a month in your paycheck
but you get a refund when you file your
taxes that's smaller by fifteen hundred
dollars you had an extra 1200 in your
pocket during the year in your paychecks
but then you lost fifteen hundred on
your tax return you end up 300 behind
your effective tax rate has gone up
changing withholding to give people more
money week to week even though in total
they might end up with less money again
if you are uneducated you're more likely
to be tricked by that this is not a
value judgment
let's look at a little bit more of this
Donald Trump was running and I said
finally another businessman and I got
fired up has he lived up to your
expectations absolutely I think he can
he's doing just fine if he says this is
what I'm going to do at this timeline he
does it well he hasn't built the wall
that was one of his main promises so I
mean do you hold that promise against
him no because isn't the whole wall part
of getting the money from Congress too
and isn't Congress stopping him from
getting the money first of all another
businessman like what model do we have
of successful presidents having been
businessmen we don't this was another
issue I'm a good businessman so I'll be
a good president now think that through
question one is was Trump actually a
good businessman it doesn't no I mean
it's unclear when you consider the
bankruptcies the fact that he started
with Millions from his dad maybe he is
maybe he isn't but the real question is
why does being a good businessman if
that's what you are make you a good
president another person who fell for
True bottom of the barrel meaningless
talking points and then of course she
phrased it as she Praises Trump for
doing what he says he would do she gets
an example of something he promised and
didn't do the wall well then default to
somebody else's so this sadly
is much more common than we would hope
in American politics now I'm sure These
are nice women I don't think anyone is a
worse person because they aren't
educated but there is no question that
certain types of Base political
arguments work better are more effective
on less educated people and that's what
we're seeing here why do I want to teach
critical thinking starting in middle
school why should we teach Civics and
philosophy and epistemology because if
you get that type of thinking ingrained
in people at an early age a lot of these
bamboozler politicians who count on
impossible promises that a more
sophisticated person would never fall
for they never get themselves elected
and it's really important to understand
also that not everybody who voted for
Trump has been tricked there are people
who voted for Trump because they knew
what it was that he was going to do and
it was good for them and they got it
okay so it's really important to
understand that this is only one part of
Donald Trump's electorate but it was an
important part and when you look at the
numbers these are the folks that are
overwhelmingly with Trump this is
important stuff this is important stuff
that relates to education it relates to
Media it relates to issues it relates to
empathy I mean there are so many things
that relate to people falling for
talking points in the way that these
women have
that's why it's important to discuss and
we're going to keep talking about it for
sure